The food is terrible.
Worst shit I've ever seen, man.
What you say?
You got any biscuits over there?
I keep seeing corn bread.
- I am cold.
- Still with us, Brett?
Right.
Oh, I feel dead.
Anybody ever tell you
you look dead, man?
Oh, yeah, right.
Now, I just
forgot something, man.
Before we dock,
I think we oughta discuss
the bonus situation.
Right.
Brett and I, we think we oughta-
- we deserve full shares, right, baby?
- You see, Mr. Parker and I...
feel that the bonus situation
has never been on an equitable level.
Well, you'll get what you're
contracted for like everybody else.
Yes, but everybody else
gets more than us.
Dallas, Mother
wants to talk to you.
Huh? Yeah, I saw it.
Yellow light's for my eyes only.
OK, get dressed, huh?
Parker, come on.
Can I finish my coffee? Thank you.
It's the only thing
good on this ship.
Morning, Mother.
- Right.
- OK.
Plug us in.
Thank you.
Where's Earth?
You should know.
It's not our system.
Scan.
I can't believe this.
Contact Traffic Control.
This is commercial towing vehicle
Nostromo out of the Solomons.
Registration number:
1-8-0-niner-2-4-6-0-niner.
Calling Antarctica Traffic Control.
Can you read me? Over.
Commercial towing vehicle
Nostromo out of the Solomons,
registration number...
- Nothing.
- Keep trying.
Calling Antarctica Traffic Control.
Do you read me, Antarctica? Over.
I found it.
Just short of Zeta II Reticuli.
We haven't reached
the outer rim yet.
That's hard to believe.
What the hell are we doing out here?
I don't know.
What the hell are you talking about?
- That's not our system.
- I know that.
Do you ever notice
how they never come down here?
I mean, this is where
the work is, right?
Well, it's the same damn reason
we get a half share to their one.
Our time is their time.
That's the way they see it.
- No, but...
- Same old shit, man.
I think I know why they
don't come down here.
It's because of you.
You don't have the personality.
Wonder what they want now.
What's going on down here?
- Um, you happen to be in my seat.
Can I have it? - Yes, of course.
- Thank you.
- I'm sorry.
What's happenin' now, baby?
Well,
some of you may have
figured out we're not home yet.
- We're only halfway there.
- What?
Mother's interrupted
the course of our journey.
- Why?
- Yeah.
She's programmed to do that should
certain conditions arise. They have.
- Like what?
- It seems she has...
intercepted a transmission
of unknown origin.
- She got us up to check it out.
- A transmission? Out here?
- Yeah.
- What kind of a transmission?
Acoustical beacon.
It repeats at intervals of 12 seconds.
- S.O.S.?
- I don't know.
Human?
- Unknown.
- Well, so what?
We are obligated under section eight...
I hate to bring this up, but, uh,
this is a commercial ship,
not a rescue ship.
- Right. - And it's not in my contract
to do this kind of duty.
And what about the money?
If you wanna give me some money,
I'll be happy to oblige.
- The man's right.
- Let's go over the bonus situation.
- I'm sorry. Can I say something?
- Let's talk about the bonus more.
There is a clause in the contract
which specifically states...
any systematised transmission indicating
a possible intelligent origin...
- must be investigated.
- I don't wanna hear it.
We don't know if it's intelligent.
I wanna go home and party.
Parker, will you
just listen to the man?
On penalty of total forfeiture
of shares.
No money.
You got that?
- Well... yeah.
- All right, we're going in.
Yeah. We're goin' in, aren't we?
Can we all hear that, Lambert?
Good God.
Doesn't sound like
any radio signal I've heard.
- Maybe it's a voice.
- Well, we'll soon know.
Can you hone in on that?
What was the, uh, position?
6550-99.
All right.
It found the quadrant.
Ascension: 6 minutes, 20 seconds.
Declination:
39 degrees, 2 seconds.
OK. Put that on the screen for me.
All right. Well, that's it.
It's a planetoid.
1200 kilometres.
It's tiny.
Any rotation?
About two hours.
What about gravity?
Point eight-six.
You can walk on it.
Approaching orbital apogee.
Mark 12, 11...
Equatorial orbit nailed.
Nine, eight seconds on descent.
- Grids energised. Fields focused.
- Five. Four...
- D.O.R.'s on line.
- How's the status on the lifters?
Give me an A.C. pressure reading.
Forty-eight seconds and counting.
SR-1 stable.
Prepare to disengage
from platform.
Mark, 20 seconds.
Eighteen, 17-
Twelve, 11, 10,
nine, eight, seven...
six, five, four,
three, two, one, lock.
Disengage.
Umbilicus clear.
Money's safe.
Let's take her down.
Nine, eight, seven-
Roll 92 degrees port yaw.
Prime to port.
Prime ventral.
Prime dorsal.
Down a degree.
39,000 metres.
Turbulence.
Locked and floating. You can drop us
anytime now. We'll catch you.
Inertial damping's going off. Hold on,
people.There's gonna be a little bump.
What the hell was that?
Pressure drop in intake three.
Must've lost a shield.
Let's go with it.
Dropping off now.
Still dropping.
Here we are. We've got it.
Take her down.
Navigation lights on.
We've got 5-3 still out.
No problem. Just down 11%.
Grid status OK.
Nine,
eight, seven, six,
five, four, three,
two, one.
Kill drive engines.
What the hell happened?
Somebody give me a straight answer!
Is the hull breached?
I don't see anything.
We've still got pressure.
Hit the screen.
Right.
Secondary load sharing unit...
is out.
Three to four cells are gone.
- Is that it?
- No, hold on, uh...
We can't fix it out here anyway,
and we need to reroute...
- a couple of these ducts, wouldn't
you say, Brett? - Dry dock time.
Dry dock.
Tell her we need to dry-dock.
Look, we couldn't fix it
out here anyway.
We gotta reroute
all these ducts,
and in order to do that
we've got to dry-dock.
What else?
Some fragments kicked up and
we've got to clean it all out
and repressurise it.
How long before
we're functional?
- Look, what is... what...
- It's 17 hours, tell her.
- At least 25 hours.
- Yeah.
Get started on the floor panel.
I'll be right down.
What the hell's she
comin' down here for?
She better stay the fuck out
of my way, I'll tell you that.
I'd like to see what she's
gonna do when she gets here.
- Any response yet?
- No. Absolutely nothing.
Except the same transmission
every 12 seconds.
All the other channels are dead.
Kick on the floods.
- We can't go anywhere in this.
- Mm.
Well, Mother says the sun's
coming up in 20 minutes.
- How far are we from the source
of transmission? - Uh, northeast.
Just under 2,000 metres.
Walking distance?
Well...
- Can you give me an atmospheric?
- Yes.
Oh.
It's almost primordial.
There's inert nitrogen,
high concentration of
carbon dioxide crystals, methane.
I'm working on the trace elements.
Anything else?
Yes. It's...
rock, lava base,
and... deep cold.
- Well below the line.
- Mm-hm.
I'll volunteer to be in
the first group to go out.
Yeah, that figures.
You too, Lambert.
Swell.
Better break out the weapons.
I can't see a god damn thing.
Ash, are you receiving?
Good contact on my board.
Clear and free.
Keep the line open.
Let's go.
Hey, Ripley.
Hey, Ripley,
I wanna ask you a question.
If they find what they're lookin' for out
there, does that mean we get full shares?
Don't worry, Parker, yeah.
You'll get whatever's coming to you.
Look, I'm not gonna do
any more work
- till we get this straightened out.
- Brett,
you're guaranteed by law to get a share.
- What?
- Why don't you just fuck off.
What'd you say, Rip?
If you have any trouble,
I'll be on the bridge.
Hey, Ripley, come back here!
- Son of a bitch.
- What's the matter?
Can't see a god damn thing.
- Quit griping.
- I like griping.
Come on. Knock it off.
Ash, can you see this?
Yes, I can.
I've never seen anything like it.
Very bizarre.
You said it.
All right.
Moving on to second...
position.
What is it?
Let's get out of here.
We've got this far.
We must go on.
We have to go on.
Will you say that again?
Shit.
Ash, as you can see,
it's kind of hard to describe.
I'm going back to the console.
Seems to be solid.
- To walk...
- You can... on it.
Dallas?
Come on down here.
Something different down here.
I don't know what it is, but...
See if we can get up that wall. If we
can get up that wall, we can find out.
Amazing.
Alien life-form.
Looks like it's been dead
a long time.
Fossilised.
Looks like it's
grown out of the chair.
Bones are bent outward,
like he exploded from inside.
Wonder what happened
to the rest of the crew.
Let's get the hell out of here.
Hey, Dallas, Lambert,
come on over here.
Come on.
- What do you got?
- See what you make of this.
Ash.
That transmission-
Mother's deciphered part of it.
- It doesn't look like an S.O.S.
- What is it, then?
Well, I...
It looks like a warning.
- I'm gonna go out after them.
- What's the point?
I mean, by the time
it takes to get there, you'll...
they'll know if it's
a warning or not, yes?
You OK down there?
- Can you see anything?
- Uh... a cave.
A ca... a cave of some sort.
But I...
Well, I don't know, but it's like
the god damn tropics in here.
What the hell is this?
The cave is
completely enclosed,
and it's full of...
leathery objects, like
eggs or something.
There's a layer of mist...
just covering the eggs
that reacts when broken.
Kane?
You all right?
I'm OK. All right.
I'm OK. I just slipped.
Appears to be completely sealed.
Wait a minute. There's movement.
It seems to have life. Organic life.
- You there, Ripley?
- I'm right here.
OK, Ripley, I'm at the
inner lock hatch now.
Right.
- Ripley. We're clean. Let us in.
- Right here.
- What happened to Kane?
- Something has attached itself to him.
- We have to get him to the infirmary
right away. - What kind of thing?
- I need a clear definition.
- An organism. Open the hatch.
Wait a minute. If we let it in,
the ship could be infected.
You know the quarantine procedure-
24 hours for decontamination.
He could die in 24 hours.
Open the hatch.
Listen to me. If we break quarantine,
we could all die.
Look, would you open the god damn hatch?
We have to get him inside.
No. I can't do that.
And if you were in my position,
you'd do the same.
Ripley, this is an order. Open
that hatch right now. Do you hear me?
Yes.
Ripley, this is an order!
Do you hear me?
Yes, I read you.
The answer is negative.
Inner hatch opened.
My God.
What the hell is that?
Jesus
Christ.
What is that, man?
Hey, how the hell is he breathing?
Is he still alive or what?
Why don't you guys freeze him?
How come they don't freeze him?
What's going on in there?
- What the fuck is going on?
- You bitch!
Jesus Christ! Hey! Hey!
- You would've left us out there.
- Break it up.
Ripley, when I give an order,
I expect to be obeyed.
- Even if it's against the law?
- You're god damn right!
Maybe she has a point, you know?
Who the hell knows what that thing is.
How are we gonna get that off him?
- How are we gonna get it off?
- I'm gonna get some instruments.
My God.
Right.
I'll make an incision here.
Try and remove
one of the digitals from...
You're gonna do what?
Finger. I'm gonna try to
get his finger off. Just a minute.
There's one there.
No, that's not... it's tearing his scalp.
- I know!
It's not coming off
without tearing his face off with it.
We'll have to take a look at him inside.
Right.
How come they don't freeze him?
How come you guys
don't freeze him?
All right,
you can take your mask off.
What's it got down his throat?
I would suggest
it's feeding him oxygen.
Paralyses him,
puts him in a coma,
then keeps him alive.
Now what the hell is that?
- We gotta get it off him.
- Just a minute. Just a minute.
I mean, let's not be too hasty.
We don't know anything about...
it.
Now, we're assuming it's feeding
him oxygen. If we remove it,
it could kill him.
I'm willing to take that chance.
Let's cut it off him now.
You'll take responsibility?
Yes, yes, I'll take responsibility.
Now get him out of there.
Where do you wanna do this?
We'll make an incision just
below the knuckle there.
- Right here.
- Stand by.
Good God!
That crap's gonna
eat through the hull.
That thing's gonna eat through
the god damn hull. Come on!
What's going on?
This way.
Next deck.
There it is.
Don't get under it!
Don't get under it.
Looks like it's stopping.
- Take a look at this, man.
- Yeah.
Brett, give me, uh... what do you got,
a pen there? Give it to me, quick.
Come on! Come on!
Don't get any on your arm.
It stopped.
Don't see anything like that except, uh,
molecular acid.
It must be using it for blood.
It's got a wonderful
defence mechanism.
You don't dare kill it.
What about Kane?
Here's your pen back.
What do we do now?
Leave Kane to Ash.
You get back to work.
Well, what...
OK.
Try it.
Damn it.
I thought sure that was it.
Try it again.
I feel like I've been
in this place a month.
We shouldn't have landed
in this place in the first place.
Shouldn't have landed on this damn ball,
I know that.
Well, the sooner we patch this
thing up and get out of here,
the sooner we can go home.
This place gives me the creeps.
That's amazing. What is it?
Ah, yes, it is. Um...
I don't know yet.
Did you want something?
Yes. I, uh...
I'd like to have a little talk.
How's, uh, how's Kane?
He's holding. No changes.
And, uh,
our guest?
Well...
Hm?
Well, as I said, I'm still...
collating, actually, but, uh,
I have confirmed that he's got an
outer layer of protein polysaccharides.
He has a funny habit of
shedding his cells
and replacing them with...
polarised silicon,
which gives him
a prolonged resistance
to adverse environmental conditions.
- Is that enough for you?
- That's plenty.
What does it mean?
Please don't do that. Thank you.
I'm sorry.
Well, it's an interesting
combination of elements,
making him a
tough little son of a bitch.
And you let him in.
I was obeying
a direct order, remember?
Ash, when Dallas and Kane
are off the ship,
I'm senior officer.
Oh, yes. I forgot.
You also forgot the science division's
basic quarantine law.
- No, that I didn't forget.
- Oh, I see. You just broke it.
Huh?
Look, what would you have done
with Kane? Hm?
You knew his only chance of survival
was to get him in here.
Unfortunately,
by breaking quarantine,
you risk everybody's life.
Maybe I should've
left him outside.
Maybe I've jeopardised the rest of us,
but it was a risk I was willing to take.
That's a pretty big risk...
for a science officer.
It's, uh, not exactly
out of the manual, is it?
I do take my responsibilities
as seriously as you, you know.
You do your job...
and let me do mine, yes?
- Where's Dallas?
- In the shuttle.
Dallas.
I think you should
have a look at Kane.
Why?
Something's happened.
Serious?
Interesting.
Ripley, meet me
in the infirmary right away.
Where is it?
Well, I don't know. I mean,
we ought to try and find it.
Yeah, let's check it.
Dallas, please be careful.
Sorry.
No, not in the corner.
Psst.
Have one of these.
Just in case.
Kane?
Dallas?
You OK?
I didn't see it.
Was it in the overhead?
- What?
- It was up there somewhere.
My God.
- Cover up the damn thing, will you?!
- Wait.
That's alive!
That's a reflex action.
Well, we've gotta
have a look at this.
Excuse me.
- Seems dead enough.
- Well, good. Let's get rid of it.
Ripley, for God's sake,
this is the first time that we've
encountered a species like this.
It has to go back.
All sorts of tests have to be made.
Ash, are you kidding?
This thing bled acid.
Who knows what it's
gonna do when it's dead.
Think it's safe to assume
it isn't a zombie.
Dallas, it has to go back.
Well, I'd soon...
as not burn it at the stake,
but you're the science officer.
- It's your decision, Ash.
- Dallas.
How come I've got to change my mind?
The decision's been made.
I'm not trying to change your mind,
Dallas. I just want you to listen...
Will you listen...
Just tell me how you can
leave that kind of decision to him.
Look, I just run the ship.
Anything that has to do with the
science division, Ash has the final word.
- How does that happen?
- It happens, my dear, because that's
what the company wants to happen.
Since when is that
standard procedure?
Standard procedure is to do
what the hell they tell you to do.
What's happening with the
repairs? How's it going?
They're pretty much finished now.
Why the hell
didn't you tell me so?
- Because there's still some things
left to do. - Like what?
Well, we're blind
on 'B' and 'C' decks.
- The reserve power system's blown...
- That's a bunch of horseshit.
- We can take off without that. - Yeah,
we can. You think that's a good idea?
Look, I just wanna get
the hell out of here, all right?
Dust in the intakes again.
Number two's overheating.
Spit on it for two minutes,
would you, for Christ's sake?
We're hot.
We're getting hotter.
Engine room, red clip status?
One kilometre on ascension.
Engage artificial gravity.
Engaged.
I'm altering the vector now.
Inhibit C.N.G. control.
- Struts retract.
- Struts retracted.
Max stress to fifth overload.
Ease it back.
She's great. Beautiful.
Walk in the park.
When we fix something, we stay fixed.
Don't we, Brett baby?
Right.
What I think we should do
is just freeze him.
If he's got a disease,
why don't we stop it where it is?
- He can always get to a doctor
when we get back home. - Right.
Whenever he says anything,
you say "right", Brett. You know that?
Right.
Parker, what do you think? Your staff
just follows you around, says "right."
- Like a regular parrot.
- Yeah. Shape up.
- What are you, some kind of parrot?
- Right.
Oh, come on. Knock it off!
Kane's gonna have to go into quarantine.
- That's it.
- Yes, and so will we.
Well, how about a little something
to lower your spirits?
Thrill me, will you, please?
Well, according
to my calculations,
based on time spent getting
to and from the planet...
- Just give me the short version.
How far to Earth? - Ten months.
- Oh, God.
- Great.
Yes.
Dallas, I think you should
come and see Kane.
- Has his condition changed?
- It's simpler if you'd just
come and see him.
We're on our way.
Right.
How are you doing?
Thank you.
How you doin'?
Terrific. Next silly question.
Oh, thank you.
Do you remember anything
about the planet?
What's the last thing
you do remember?
Huh?
I remember some...
horrible dream about...
smothering. And...
And...
Anyway, where are we?
- Right here.
- We're on our way home.
Yeah, back to the old freezerinos.
Could I have something to eat
before we go back?
I-I need something myself.
Yeah, right. One more meal
before bedtime. I'm buyin'.
- Hey, that's a break.
- Bedtime.
What happened to the guy...
The first thing that I'm gonna do
when I get back...
is to get some decent food.
I can dig it, man. Let me tell you,
I've eaten worse food than this,
- but then I've tasted better,
you know what I'm sayin'?
- The other one over there.
You pound down the stuff
like there's no tomorrow.
I'd rather be eatin' something else,
but, uh, right now I'm thinkin' food.
Well, you should know.
You know what it's made of.
No, man, I don't wanna talk
about what it's made of.
I'm eatin' this just to...
What's the matter?
- The food ain't that bad, baby.
- What's wrong, Kane?
Are you choking?
What's wrong?
What? What?
- This is serious.
- Kane, what's the matter?
Hold him down!
Hold him...
Get the spoon in!
Damn it!
- Get it into his mouth!
- I'm trying!
Oh, my God! Oh, God!
- No!
- Don't touch it! Don't touch it!
Dallas?
Yeah.
Anything?
No. You?
Nothing.
- You see anything?
- No.
Inner hatch sealed.
Anybody wanna say anything?
This is just an ordinary prod,
like a cattle prod.
It's got a portable battery.
It's insulated all the way here,
all the way up to here.
Just make damn sure nobody
puts their hand on the end of it.
It shouldn't damage
the little bastard,
unless its skin's
thinner than ours.
But it will give him
a little incentive.
Now we just have to find it.
I've taken care of that.
I've designed this tracking device.
You just set it to search
for a moving object, like so.
Hasn't got much of a range but
when you get within a certain distance,
it'll start to give off a signal.
What's it key on?
Micro changes in air density.
Give me a demo.
- See?
- Again.
Got ya.
Two teams.
Ash,
Lambert and I.
Ripley, you take Parker and Brett.
Now, anyone see this thing,
you catch it in the net
that Parker's holding
on his lap.
Parker, I don't want
any heroics out of you, all right?
Catch it, put it in the air lock,
get rid of it.
Now, channels are open
on all decks.
I want you to communicate,
keep in touch at all times, all right?
Let's go.
I thought you fixed 12 module.
We did.
I don't understand it.
The circuits must have burned out.
- What do we got here?
- Damn it! Hold your light
over here, would you?
Yeah, that's it.
- I don't know if this is going to work.
- Right.
If I could just put this--
put this in there.
Right.
Oh, damn it.
Check the insulation.
Oh, shit!
Steady.
According to this,
it's within 5 metres.
Micro changes
in air density, my ass.
It's within 5 metres.
Be careful.
Christ. Don't do that.
Don't creep up on me with that thing.
You guys, stick together.
Don't fail me now.
What?
- What is it?
- Parker, Brett, it's in this locker!
Where?
Here, take this.
Get over there and get the net.
- Get it?
- I got it. I got it. I got it.
Wait a minute.
All right, Parker.
When I say.
All right. Now.
Easy.
Wait! Don't let him go!
What the hell are you doing, man?
It's the cat.
Hey, look, now.
We had to bag it, man.
Now we might pick it up
on the tracker again.
- I'll... I'll... I'll...
- Go and get it, man.
All right. You get him. We'll go on.
Here, kitty!
Here, kitty, kitty!
Enough of that kitty crap.
Jones.
Jonesy?
Here, Jonesy.
Meow.
Jonesy?
Here, kitty, kitty, kitty.
Here, Jonesy.
Jonesy?
Here, kitty, kitty.
Kitty, kitty, kitty.
Here, Jonesy.
Jonesy.
Kitty, kitty.
Kitty, kitty, kitty.
Jonesy?
Hey. Hey. Come on, Jonesy.
Come on, baby. That's a kitty.
That's a kitty. Come on, baby.
That's a kitty.
Hey, hey.
I'm not gonna hurt you.
Come on.
Brett!
Whatever it was, it was...
it was big and...
You're sure it took him
into the air shaft?
Disappeared into
one of the cooling ducts.
No question, it's...
it's using the air ducts
to move around.
Could he want Brett alive?
- What?
- Could Brett be alive?
No. I mean, I don't think so.
Well,
this air shaft
may work to our advantage.
Here it leads up to and
comes out in the main air lock.
All right. There's only one big opening
along the way.
We can cover that up,
and then we...
drive it into the air lock and
zap it into outer space.
This son of a bitch is huge!
I mean, it's like a man. It's big!
Kane's son.
Come on, Ash. I mean, Science
department should be able to help us.
What can we do to drive it?
Yes, well, it's adapted
remarkably well to our atmosphere,
considering its
nutritional requirements.
- The only thing we don't
know about is temperature.
- OK. What about temperature?
- What happens if we change it?
- Let's try it.
I mean, most animals
retreat from fire. Yes?
Fire, yeah.
Parker, can you rig...
three or four incinerator units?
Give me about 20 minutes. I'll do it.
Who gets to go into the vent?
I do.
No.
You and Ash...
take the main air lock.
Parker, Lambert, you cover up
that maintenance opening, please.
Right.
I'm at the first junction.
Dallas, I'm right here.
- Parker?
- Yeah?
Lambert?
We're in position.
I'm just trying to get a reading here.
The air lock is open.
OK, Ripley.
Ready.
All right. I've got
a reading on you now.
Uh, open the hatch
to the third junction.
OK, I'm through.
- Ripley?
- Yes.
Close all the hatches behind me.
I'm moving on.
Dallas, hold it a minute.
I think I got it.
Yes, I've got it.
Where?
It's somewhere around
the third junction.
OK, moving on.
It is right around there. Now, Dallas,
you're gonna have to be careful.
All right.
I've reached...
the third junction,
and I'm going down.
The hell's the matter
with that box?
Dallas, you're gonna have to
hold your position for a minute. I...
I've lost the signal.
What?
- You sure?  - Look around.
Are you sure it's not there?
I mean, it's got to be
around there somewhere.
Checked it out, Lambert.
You may be getting interference.
Dallas, are you sure there is
no sign of it? I mean, it is there.
It's gotta be around there.
Dallas?
God, what is happening?
All right.
Uh,
am I... am I clear, Lambert?
I want to get the hell out of here.
Oh, God. It's moving
right towards you.
Um...
Move! Get out of there!
Behind you! Move!
Dallas! Move, Dallas!
Move, Dallas!
Get out!
Move!
The other way! Dallas!
Dallas?
- Oh, no.
- Take it easy.
Dallas?
We found this laying there.
No blood.
No Dallas.
Nothing.
- I don't hear anybody sayin' nothing...
- I'm thinking.
Unless somebody has got
a better idea,
we'll proceed with Dallas's plan.
What? And end up
like the others?
Oh. No, you're
out of your mind.
- Got a better idea?
- Yes. I say that we abandon this ship.
We get the shuttle and just
get the hell out of here.
We take our chances
and just hope that
- somebody picks us up.
- Lambert.
- The shuttle won't take four.
- Then why don't we draw straws and...
I'm not drawin' any straws. I'm for
killing that god damn thing right now.
OK.
Well, let's talk about killing it.
We know it's using the air shafts...
Will you listen to me, Parker?
- Shut up!
- Let's hear it.
Let's hear it.
It's using the air shafts.
- We don't know that.
- That's the only way.
We'll move in pairs.
We'll go step by step
and cut off every bulkhead
and every vent
until we have it cornered, and then
we'll blow it the fuck out into space.
Is that acceptable to you?
- If it means killing it,
it's acceptable to me.
- Obviously it means killing it.
But we have to stick together.
- How are our weapons?
- The weapons are fine.
- This one needs refuelling.
- Will you get it, please?
- Ash, go with him.
- No, no. I can manage, Ash.
Don't follow me.
Ash?
Any suggestions from you or Mother?
No, we're still collating.
You're what?
You're still collating?
I find that hard to believe.
- What would you like me to do?
- Just what you've been doing, Ash.
Nothing.
I've got access to Mother now,
and I'll get my own answers,
thank you.
All right.
There is an explanation
for this, you know.
Is there really?
I don't wanna hear
your god damn explanation!
I want- I want-
I want- I w-
Parker. Lambert?
Ash,
open the door.
Ash-
Will you open the door?
Let me by, Ash.
Yaah!
The hell are you doing?
Aah!
Get her up. Get her up. Get her up.
Android! He's an android!
Jesus!
It's a robot.
Ash is a god damn robot!
God!
Oh! Get off me- Oh!
Holy shit!
Help! Help me get
this fucking thing off!
Aah!
God! Jesus!
Oh, God! Oh, God!
Oh, God!
How come the company
sent us a god damn robot?
All I can think of is they must've wanted
the alien for their weapons division.
He's been protecting it right along.
Parker, will you plug it in?
- I don't know why-
- Because he may know how to kill it.
Ash, can you hear me?
Ash?
Yes, I can hear you.
- What was your special order?
- You read it. I thought it was clear.
- What was it?
- Bring back life-form.
Priority one.
All other priorities rescinded.
The damn company! What about
our lives, you son of a bitch?
I repeat: All other priorities
are rescinded.
How do we kill it, Ash?
There's got to be a way of killing it.
How- How do we do it?
You can't.
That's bullshit!
You still don't understand what
you're dealing with, do you?
A perfect organism.
Its structural perfection
is matched only by its hostility.
You admire it.
I admire its purity.
A survivor...
unclouded
by conscience,
remorse
or delusions of morality.
Look, I-- I've heard
enough of this,
and I'm asking you
to pull the plug.
Last word.
What?
I can't lie to you
about your chances, but...
you have my sympathies.
We're gonna blow up the ship.
We'll take our chances
in the shuttle.
- Blow up the ship.
- Good.
Come on.
- When we throw the switches,
how long before the ship blows?
- Ten minutes.
- No bullshit.
- If we ain't outta here in 10 minutes,
we won't need no rocket
to fly through space.
We're gonna need coolant
for the air support system.
You two go down,
get all the coolant you can carry.
I'll get the shuttle ready.
I'll give you about-
about seven minutes.
Come back up here.
I'll shut the switches off,
and we'll blow this fucker
off into space.
OK. All right. Come on.
- Ready?
- Take care of yourself.
Seven minutes.
Take it easy.
Jones.
Jones?
OK, check the bottles.
- How you doin'?
- Fine.
Kitty.
OK. Go ahead.
Jones?
Psst! Psst! Psst! Psst!
Kitty, kitty, kitty, kitty, kitty.
Come here, Jones.
Come here.
Jones?
Come here, boy.
Come here.
Nice kitty.
Jones?
Come here.
Come here, sweetheart.
Jones.
Jones? Jones?
Jones?
Oh, God!
Jones!
God damn it!
Now I got you.
Here, sweetie.
Nice kitty.
Urgh.
Oh, my God...
- Get out of the way.
- I can't get out of the way!
Get out of the way, Lambert!
It's gonna kill us!
I can't!
- Lambert, for Christ's sake,
get out of the way!
- Parker? Lambert-
Get out of the way, Lambert!
Parker?
Lambert?
Lambert? Parker?
Get outta the room!
Oh, God!
Parker?
Danger.
The emergency destruct system
is now activated.
The ship will detonate
in T-minus
ten minutes.
The option to override
automatic detonation
expires in T-minus
five minutes.
The option to override
automatic detonation
expires in T-minus...
Oh!
Dallas.
Brett.
Oh.
Kill me.
Kill me!
The option to override
automatic detonation
expires in T-minus
three minutes.
The option to override
automatic detonation expires
in T-minus one minute.
Twenty-nine, 28, 27,
26, 25, 24,
23, 22,
21, 20 seconds.
Nineteen, 18,
17, 16,
15, 14, 13,
12, 11, 10 seconds.
Nine, eight, seven,
six, five, four,
- Come on!
- three, two, one.
The option to override
detonation procedure
has now expired.
Mother? I've turned
the cooling unit back on.
Mother!
The ship will automatically destruct
in T-minus 5 minutes.
You bitch!
Argh!
God damn it!
Jonesy.
You now have one minute
to abandon ship.
The ship will automatically destruct
in T-minus one minute.
T-minus 30 seconds.
Twenty-nine, 28,
27, 26,
25, 24,
23, 22, 21,
20 seconds.
Nineteen, 18,
17, 16,
15, 14, 13,
12, 11, 10 seconds.
Nine, eight, seven,
six, five,
four, three, two, one.
I got you,
you son of a bitch.
Shh, shh, shh, shh, shh.
It's all right.
Shh, shh, shh.
Shh, shh, shh. It's all right.
All right. It's nice
to see you too.
Shh, shh, shh, shh.
It's OK.
Come on. Come on.
# You are #
# My lucky star #
# You... are my #
# Lucky star #
# You #
Lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky, lucky.
OK.
Well, come on.
# You are #
# My lucky star #
# You #
# You are my lucky star #
# You are my lucky #
Oh, my God.
My- My lucky-
# You... are my... #
# You are my #
# Lucky #
Final report of the commercial
starship Nostromo.
Third officer reporting.
The other members of the crew-
Kane, Lambert,
Parker, Brett,
Ash and Captain Dallas
are dead.
Cargo and ship destroyed.
I should reach the frontier
in about six weeks.
With a little luck,
the network will pick me up.
This is Ripley,
last survivor of the Nostromo,
signing off.
Come on, cat.